hey Dad can you transfer me some money  you've got a full-time job  Seamus did you use my prescription  toothpaste no it it's mine it's being  expensive get your own  the  if I'm gonna give you money I want to  know what it's for I need to buy toilet  paper toilet paper yeah how do you not  have coffee I've just gotten by without  it how is that possible because I've  been holding in my purse for work  hey Nick my cousins are visiting Sydney  this weekend reckon we can have a party  at yours oh you can throw your own party  my parents being [ __ ] about it  alright fine  okay I'll have it you're the best one  more thing one more thing  um can you pay my rent this week  dad dad help hello let's play fifa lets  play fifa Brad please I want to sleep  the dual with sleeping here  a commode